[Music]
when I was younger all I care about was
being outside playing football football
was my dream for the longest I didn't
even go to university to study computer
science to be able not split from maths
and economics I was just going wherever
I thought the money was and then I felt
that year I'd never felt like that I set
out to kind of prove to myself but I
could do it so yeah I got my first
English computer science a Royal
Holloway I didn't know what it was until
my first lecture in computer science
probably didn't know until after my
first year but the more I found out
about it the more I've realized that
actually it fits my character it fits me
I'm doing
I still have this little booklet where
handler all my goals I was going through
it and I was taking off some of the
bigger items and I was thinking okay
the Masters I want to do this I could
get this skill and I could change my
world the course that I ended up getting
a place on was a masters in data science
on machine land at UCL I was happy I was
thrilled and then after that it was okay
how am I gonna pay for it I didn't have
anyone that I could turn to to help me
even when I did the maths I couldn't
save enough in a year to be able to do
the course and then I see the email
basically saying there's a special
opportunity to help support students
from underrepresented backgrounds and
computer science specifically from
low-income households African or
Caribbean households and women I found
out it was the deepmind scholarship and
I was like wow
myself and the other scholars have been
really fortunate in that deepmind
providing each of us with a mentor
speaking with my mentor Simon offs in
there about any and everything I can't
explain just how much it's done for me
especially being such a from figure
that's done a lot of great work having
access to that kind of person is yeah
invaluable
I am currently working on protein
structure prediction using deep learning
which is super important for lots of
things there isn't a cure for sickle
cell which is fundamentally a protein
folding problem a problem that actually
affects mostly African and Caribbean
people I want to be able to kind of push
the envelope and say hey we have this
problem in it solving to specifically in
computer science especially with
technologies such as AI that have the
potential to be extremely transformative
in society I think we need to have as
many people around the table making
decisions that are going to influence
you know everyone if we don't have that
we can end up propagating our prejudices
and our biases from today's society into
tomorrow's I wouldn't have been able to
do the course without scholarship I
wouldn't have access to someone like
Simon it's life-changing I am a deep
mind scholar
you